only on CBS this morning we're hearing
more from the women who accused
Virginia's lieutenant governor of sexual
assault
Vanessa Tyson and Meredith Watson say
they've never met they both want to
testify in front of the Virginia General
Assembly against Justin Fairfax who was
second in line for the governor's seat
now he denies their assault allegations
adamantly Watson went public just days
after Tyson she claims that Fairfax
assaulted and raped her in 2000 when
they were both students at Duke
University some of the details that she
shared with us are very disturbing how
did you know Justin Fairfax we've met at
the end of my freshman year of college
we were very good friends he was someone
I really trusted and during my junior
year one night
he invited me to come over to celebrate
he was nearing the end of his senior
year and just wanted to hang out and I
did not think anything of it because it
was normal it was something we've done
tons and tons and tons of time so it
wasn't the first time you guys had just
hung out together nothing no it was not
so you didn't feel you were in danger
you had no concerns you weren't worried
I was not worried at all I'd completely
trusted him we were hanging out and
everything was normal and at one point
he left the room and when he came back
in the room he stored it sort of stood
blocking the door was sort of imposing
the way he walked in the room and he
shut the door and it was sort of like
simultaneous I heard the door click and
the light went off click like locking
the door and you think what oh no what's
about to happen you became concerned
and he did things that you shouldn't do
to someone without their permission
mm-hmm
and I tried several times to get up and
leave and was push back down and what
happened he forcibly sexually assaulted
and raped me I was not on the bed
initially there was a couch and he
pulled me over and I tried several times
to get up and was pushed back down held
down and you made it clear this is not
what I want it was very clear because
you know he is saying this night was
consensual if you have to hold someone
down it's not consensual and when it was
over was there a conversation What did
he say what did you say what did he do
there wasn't a conversation I just
wanted to get to a safe space I just
left it was humiliating and so I left
and I told my two closest friends what
did you tell you two closest friends I
believe I told them that something
really awful had happened and that I had
been raped and I think I said that I was
so humiliated I didn't want to talk
about it anymore
did you tell them that Justin was the
one who had done this to you you just
said I told them exactly who it was how
do you process that after it happens to
you it was a huge betrayal he was my
friend
I don't understand what you do that to
somebody that you've been a friend to
and he was confided in you about things
I just don't understand how did he do
that what kind of things did you confide
to him he knew that the year prior that
I had been raped by someone and that
nothing was done about it and he was a
very good friend to me which is why I
never would have expected anything like
this from him and you've been very
candid that you had been sexually
assaulted before by a Duke basketball
player did you tell anybody about that
particular incident I did it took it
took a couple of weeks I was I didn't
really know how to respond when it first
happened but I did report it to an
official at the University you know the
experts say that many times if someone
has been sexually assaulted it it
happens again you know that it's not it
often is not an isolated incident
I think people looking at you would say
well how could it happen to her twice in
the same place at the same school
what do you say to that I don't I don't
really know what to say to that because
I don't understand how someone could
think that because it happens once it
could never happen again
I just don't underst I don't understand
that you know if you get in a car
accident when it bumps in your life or
you never will you never get in another
car accident now you know things happen
and I I did not ask for it to happen you
feel that Justin betrayed you because
you had confided in him about that
incident yes did you ever talk to him
after after he allegedly assaulted you
did you ever say how could you do that
to me you were my friend I did one night
after it happened it was at a party on
campus and he came and so I went to
leave
like I left and he followed me out and
was sort of following after me calling
after me and I was just running trying
to get away and then I finally stopped
and I turned around and all I said to
him was why why would you do that to me
and he said it him I knew because of
what happened to you last year that if
I've got you in the right situation you
will be too afraid to say or do anything
about it
Meredith you hear that and you think
what he knew what he was gonna do that
night when he asked me to come over in
response to Watson's allegations a
spokesperson says Fairfax took a
polygraph test and it supports his
denials that's according to information
released by his team character
characterizing rather the results his
spokesperson says the tests show that
Fairfax was truthful when he answered
that he never had a conversation with
Meredith Watson where she implied his
sexual contact with her was
non-consensual this spokesperson also
says that Fairfax denies ever holding
her down or preventing her from getting
up during the alleged incident meanwhile
Duke tells CBS News the university is
reviewing policies and procedures that
were in place at that time that these
events are alleged to have occurred and
whether they were activated and followed
as for Watson's claim that she'd been
assaulted by a Duke basketball player
the university also said this in
February that it first learned of that
allegation when it appeared in the press
that month and we should also say that
that Duke basketball player has gone on
record and says that he also did not
sexually assault Meredith Watson